is the reason education sucks.
and it's the same reason that it will never, ever,
ever be fixed.
because the owners of this country don't want that.
I'm talking about the real owners now.
the real owners.
the big wealthy business that control things
and make all the important decisions.
forget the politicians.
the politicians are put there to give you the idea
that you have freedom of choice.
you don't. you have no choice.
you have owners.
they own you.
they own everything.
they own all the important lands.
they own and control the corporations.
they've long since bought and paid for the Senate,
the Congress,
the State houses,
the city halls.
they got the judges in their back pockets.
and they own all the media company.
so they control
just about all of the news and information
you get to hear.
they got you by the balls.
they spend billions of dollars every year lobbying,
lobbying to get what they want.
well, we know what they want.
they want more for themselves
and less for everybody else.